[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: So Dave, we meet
again. it was just-- what--
nine months ago that you
and I were hanging out here
at The 5th Nine at Next.
We were talking about
your new book, I think.
So what have you been up
to since we last spoke?
DAVE RENSIN: You
know, it's cloud.
It's only one of Google's
fastest growing businesses.
So not much.
Really video games,
rock climbing.
A lot of [INAUDIBLE].
SPEAKER: That
sounds about right.
DAVE RENSIN: Pretty sedate.
SPEAKER: Anything work related?
DAVE RENSIN: Oh, nah.
Yeah, I mean, lots of stuff.
Mostly working with customers
and doing everything
we can to teach the world
what it means to be an SRE
and how to do it well.
SPEAKER: So when
attendees come to Next,
what can they expect
when they visit us here
in The 5th Nine lounge?
DAVE RENSIN: Well,
really, what we're
hoping for is to have those deep
conversations about how it is
they go on their SRE journey.
We're still kind
of at this stage
where we have to really
prove to people that no, this
is not just something
that only works at Google.
It can work anywhere.
SPEAKER: OK, let's
get down to business
and get to the
nitty gritty of SRE.
How do we help customers
move towards implementing
SRE practices?
DAVE RENSIN: Well, so there
are two things you really
have to do.
One, you have to make it easy
for them to learn, right?
So we wrote these two
best selling books.
So we have a Coursera
course, where
we do a lot of writing
and public speaking.
And then you have
to make it easy
for them to practice
it in the tools, right?
So there was a wonderful
announcement today
from the Stackdriver team about
SLO alerting and error budget
monitoring.
So those are really
the two ways you
have to attack that problem.
SPEAKER: Fantastic.
So what is Google doing
to help our customers meet
their own SLOs?
DAVE RENSIN: I think the
best thing a customer can
do to reliably meet SLOs,
besides building good products,
is actually share their
monitoring with Google.
If you're using Stackdriver,
and you set up an SLO dashboard,
you can actually
share that with us
so that when you have difficult
moments, and you will,
it becomes faster for
everyone to debunk.
SPEAKER: Nice.
And so what is Google
doing with that product
to help customers implement
those SLOs and error
budgets themselves?
DAVE RENSIN: My
personal goal at Google
is to make sure that it's
easy in every product
to practice SRE principles,
that rollouts and rollbacks are
unimportant and easy when
you're doing them on--
I don't know-- GCE or GKE.
You saw the announcement
this morning
of our new Kubernetes
hybrid and on-prem solution.
We're going to make some
other announcements about SLO
monitoring, and burn monitoring,
and those solutions, too.
So we're really building at
every layer of the stack.
SPEAKER: Fantastic.
Now I have been hanging
out with a few SREs.
You hear a lot about
accepting failure as normal.
How do you recommend
customers go
about moving from every area
is a problem to the mindset
of failure is normal?
DAVE RENSIN: A big problem
is that for so long,
we've all been living under
the tyranny of perfection.
We expect perfection.
And I would say to
customers, tell me
one system designed by humans.
Software, hardware, economic,
political, anything you want,
that's ever been 100% reliable.
And they can't.
And you know why they can't?
Because nature has
never built one either.
So once you accept that
it's not possible to do,
then the question becomes, well,
how much failure is acceptable?
Because you're
going to have some.
And that's where then we
get into the conversations
about error budgets and SLOs.
SPEAKER: Yeah,
that's a good segue.
So how do you see
customers becoming
effective at managing the
workloads of various SRE teams?
DAVE RENSIN: OK, so there are
some good rule of thumb limits
about the number of
incidents you can really
have during an on call period
or how much of your project time
you can have.
So I think a good rule
of thumb for people
is if you see your teams
are spending at all anything
less than 50% of
their calendar time,
their clock time on
engineering projects,
they're headed for toil.
And they're not managing
their load well.
But if you come talk
to us, we can help
you inch your way through that.
SPEAKER: Absolutely,
and so speaking
of that, what are your
recommendation to customers
on how to take that first step
of their journey towards SRE?
DAVE RENSIN: Well, there are
a bunch of things you can do.
We've got two best
selling books.
If you go to google.com/sre,
you can read both of the books
for free.
We have a course in
Coursera specifically
on SLOs that's
really very popular.
If you're here at the
show, come by The 5th Nine
and talk to SREs, talk
to me or anyone else.
If you're a Google
Cloud customer,
you can talk for free with
the CRE team, the Customer
Reliability Engineering team.
We are a group of
long tenured SREs,
and our job is to teach you
how to adopt SRE and make
that easy and
comfortable for you.
SPEAKER: Fantastic.
All right, thanks, Dave.
It is always a pleasure.
DAVE RENSIN: Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]